[Music]
aziz i have to ask you we were talking
about your romantic life uh marriage uh
dating have you tried computer dating
computer dating yeah is that like online
dating yeah
computer dating is like you're going out
with an actual
computer you know what uh give me a
break i'm 77 years old
tell me of this computerized dating
it's all the rages well it's either that
or the singles bars yeah
have you tried this online dating no i
i've never done it i i have a friend he
he did it and he actually he met his
wife on one of those sites and i asked
him i was like oh would you search
because it's kind of a weirdly romantic
thing you know he types in this phrase
there's all these like algorithms and
stuff that come together this woman's
face comes up he clicks it that becomes
a woman he spends the rest of his life
with so i asked him i was like what do
you search and he goes jewish and my zip
code
what
that's all you are looking for
just something jewish close by
you don't want to drive too far
jewish that's how i found out wendy's a
few weeks ago
i typed wendy's in my zip code and then
i got some nuggets he got a wife the
exact same way
so it's not for you is what you're
saying no no no now uh am i right that
you do you do quite a bit of work uh
charity work uh for anti-bullying is
that right yeah i did a show uh not too
long ago for this uh anti-bullying
charity i i wasn't really aware of this
yesterday then i saw this documentary uh
about bullying and i know you kind of
hear that and like the first thought is
like oh really like kids getting teased
in school that's what we're making a big
deal about now and that's kind of what i
thought and then i saw the documentary
okay
first scene kid's just sitting on a bus
he looks at this other kid he goes hey
how's it going the kids just like i hate
you
i'm going to murder you and cut your
face off and put it on my face and look
in the mirror and make fun of myself
and i was like okay yeah this is a
problem that was terrifying
that's not bullying or teasing that's
like a demented kid yeah like that's not
the bullying and teasing i remember yeah
yeah i mean bullying and teasing i
remember is like oh hey you're fat hey
you're brown shut up you bozo get out of
here you ding dong that's fine no one's
gonna get hurt that's fine did you grow
up in the 1950s
what the hell are you talking about it's
kind of a little rougher than that
hey there ding dong
oh yes you go along you old ding dong
but i i don't know i it was just like it
was like really scary to see this stuff
and i just think about like
when i was a kid there was only one time
where a kid actually like
physically hit me and like the teacher
dealt with it right away the kids in
this documentary teachers don't do
anything like don't intervene they don't
really do anything like kid goes up to
the teacher in one scene he's like oh he
said he's going to cut my arms off and
glue into my butt so i look like a
minotaur
[Laughter]
these are the most creative kids
i have to give it up for these bullies
this is like
they put a lot of thought into this and
maybe the teacher was teaching ancient
greece yeah you don't know so he's like
extra credit yeah yeah but the teacher
doesn't do anything i remember one time
when i was a kid where i was actually
physically bullied and i'll never forget
what happened like i grew up in south
carolina kid hit me i went to a teacher
teacher goes up to the kid right away
and just goes if you touch him again i
will end you
and that
[Applause]
what a fantastic phrase yeah because
yeah the bullying stopped forever and
because that kid was like all right well
i don't want to be ended whatever that
means
[Laughter]